factor out the greatest common factor in
the expression they give us is 4x to the
fourth y plus 8x to the 3rd Y when they
say to factor out the greatest common
factor they're essentially telling us
find the greatest common factor of four
X to the fourth and eight X to the third
Y and factor it out of this expression
or kind of undistributed and to find
that greatest common factor and I always
put it in quotes when we speak in kind
of algebraic terms because we don't
really know what x and y are whether
they're positive and negative or whether
they're greater than or less than one so
it's not always going to be the greatest
absolute number but it's kind of the
greatest and it contains the most terms
of these two expressions these two
monomials so if we were to essentially
factor out 4 for X to the fourth Y it
would look like this we do the prime
factorization of 4 which is just 2 times
2 2 times 2 times X to the fourth which
is x times X times X times X times y
times y we've just kind of expanded it
out as a product of its basic
constituents now let's do the same thing
for 8/8 I'll color coded 8x to the 3rd
let me do this
let me do it in similar colors so we
have in this situation we have 8x to the
3rd X to the 3rd Y so the prime
factorization of 8 is 2 times 2 times 2
it's 2 times 2 times 2 prime or I should
say the factorization of X to the 3rd or
the expansion of it is just times x
times X times X X multiplied by itself
three times and then we are multiplying
everything by a Y here times y so what
factors are common to both of these and
we want to include as many of them as
possible to find this greatest common
factor so we have two 2's here three 2's
here so we only have two twos in common
two twos in common and both of them we
have four X's here only three X's here
so we only have three X's in common
three X's and three X's and we have a Y
here and a Y here so Y is common to both
- both expressions so the greatest
common factor here is going to be two
times two so it's going to be two times
two times X times X times X times y or
4x to the third for X to the third Y so
this is what we want to factor out so
that means we can write this as we can
write this thing all right as if we
factor out a 4x to the third for X to
the third Y we're essentially have to
divide each of these by four X to the
third when we're factoring it out so let
me rewrite this so this is four X to the
fourth y plus eight X to the third Y and
we're going to divide each of these by
four X to the third Y for X to the third
Y and hopefully this makes sense to you
if we were to multiply this out we would
distribute this 4x to the third Y on
each terms and then it would cancel with
the denominator you can have that the
same thing in the numerator in the
denominator same thing in the numerator
in the denominator and then you would
get this expression over here so
hopefully this makes sense that these
are the exact same expression but when
you write it this way then it becomes
pretty clear that this is four X to the
third Y and then you just simplify each
of these expressions 4 cancels with 4 X
to the fourth divided by X to the third
is X Y divided by Y is just 1 so you
have X plus 8 divided by 4 is 2 X to the
third divided by X to the third is 1 Y
divided by Y is 1 so X plus 2 another
way to kind of see what's left over when
you factor it out is if you were to take
out the common factor so we took out
this and this what was left over in for
X to the fourth Y when we took this
stuff out when we kind of undistributed
it well the only thing that was left was
this X right over here let me do that in
another color the only thing that was
left was this X so that's why we just
have that X over there when we factored
everything out of the eight X to the
third out of the 8 X to the third Y we
factored all this other stuff out we
factored out 4 X to the third Y we
factored it out so all we had left was
all we had left was the 2 now in general
you don't always have to kind of go
through this process you could have done
it
but this kind of really hopefully makes
it clear exactly what we're doing you
could have said look for X to the fourth
y plus 8 X to the 3rd Y you could have
said well let's see the largest number
that's divisible into both 4 & 8 is 4 so
let's factor out a 4 out here the
largest multiple of X is divisible into
X to the fourth and X to the 3rd well
it's going to be X to the 3rd you put an
X to the 3rd out here and you say well
the largest thing that's divisible both
into y and Y is just Y so you could have
done it a little bit faster in your head
so you factor out a 4x to the 3rd and
you said okay if I take out a 4 out of
here then this becomes a 1 if I take an
X to the third out of X to the 4 so I'll
just have an X left over and then if I
take a why out of the Y then I just have
a 1 there so this term becomes X and if
I take a 4 X to the 3rd Y out of here if
I take a 4 out of an 8 I just have a 2
left over take an X to the third out of
X to the 3rd that's just 1 if I take Y
out of Y that's just 1 so I'm just left
with X plus 2 eventually you'll just
kind of just do this in your head a
little bit faster but hopefully this
makes everything clear